who is my girl my girl has love in her
heart and snow in her eyes in her life
every birthday kiddo
mrs. Norris I'm very sorry for your loss
we have three suspects in custody but
they're all linked to the Garcia cartel
no witnesses have been willing to step
up these cartels are no joke they've got
everyone net pockets you've been through
a terrible tragedy maybe you didn't see
what you think you saw you did maybe
you've made a mistake
number three over five number four that
your recollection isn't what you thought
it was the evidence is insufficient to
hold the defendants over for trial you
think that you're gonna have justice
make them all all day
five years ago Brian or just disappeared
completely off the grid so she spends
the last five years doing what training
well that's new the honestly think Riley
North did this
today's the five year anniversary of her
family's murder
she's back
group judges dirty cops well I want
it's not a coincidence that makes this
area low crime it is low crime because
of her
[Music]
and somebody's doing something under I
don't care you have to burn this city
down watching someone take everything
from you it turned you into somebody
else
social media is lit up with support for
her she's a multiple homicide suspect
not to them she's not
up man and now God everything is gonna
go
I will kill every one of you then that
I'll pretty much wing it from there
you